okay we're doing the golden ratio and
Fibonacci numbers and I'm going to show
you why Lukas numbers are better than
Fibonacci numbers so you know it does
sound familiar doesn't it because we did
a video a couple years ago now about
Lukas numbers which Lukas numbers
instead of studying 1:1 Fibonacci they
start to 1 and then they carry on from
there then you get 3/4 I just put a
couple of them down here so we've got a
couple Lukas numbers to get us going
okay that's and then the Fibonacci
numbers which everyone already knows and
loves lining up here so they're going 1
3 you can think of Fibonacci or the 1 1
and then you get 2 3 5 8 and so on 30
people love Fibonacci AMEX there's lots
of cool things and they have the
constant ratio that as if you multiply 1
to get to the next one it's the golden
ratio
there's your multiplier as you go down
well not not exactly but it tends to the
golden ratio and what I pointed out in
our previous video is Lukas numbers do
that as well so again here the ratio
from one to the next approaches the
golden ratio in fact any sequence where
you start with two numbers and then add
them to get the next one and we repeat
always approach as the ratio of the
golden ratio and so even the Brady
numbers so if you want to that was the
origin and the Brady numbers to prove
that point there's a video where I prove
it algebraically and we look at these
and they're absolutely great and the
kind of the crux of my argument as to
why Lukas is better than Fibonacci is if
all these Fibonacci esque sequences have
that property what happens if we start
with the golden ratio is the ratio and
then work out what sequence drops out
and so what I did will show that if you
take the golden ratio and square it you
get two point six one eight the dart
which if you round it to the nearest
whole number is three and I'm not going
to do all of them again this time as you
can see what's going on here if you cube
it you get four point two three six that
which you're going to do this whole
number is four you go that's that's
looking familiar
five it equals eleven point zero nine
zero dot 11 right and so it turns out
that the Lucas numbers are just the
golden ratio raised to a power and then
rounded you square brackets for rounding
to the nearest whole value and so the
nth lucas number in this sequence is
just the golden ratio to that power
round to the nearest whole number and
I'm like boom
that's why Lucas numbers are better
because if you start with a golden ratio
and raise it to powers
what drops out the Lucas numbers some on
the internet had a different opinion
someone on reddit with quite a new
account
I think they've created it just to come
and harass me with their proof Z proxy
pylon they came at me and said Oh Matt
if you raise the gun ratio to various
powers you don't get the Lucas numbers
in fact you get a whole lot of Fibonacci
numbers and so what they did was use the
facts that famously the golden ratio
minus one equals one over the golden
ratio lovely I mean oh I'm a huge fan of
that right this this is the stuff I do
get excited about you can actually
multiply everything here by the golden
ratio and shuffle it around a little bit
and you'll see the golden ratio squared
equals the golden ratio plus 1 which is
also love as I'm stating the same thing
very nice way in fact if you then solve
this kind of quadratic equation you can
show that the golden ratio is the square
root of 5 plus 1 on to and that's where
the value comes from but the interesting
thing here is actually I worked out the
numerical value when I did God ratio
squared why don't I do it in terms of
the golden ratio you know why not keep
it as you know an exact number because
if you recall correctly Brady you
complained when I did this because I was
rounding you said it's not very precise
you know it's a bit rough and ready this
doesn't seem very much like a lot of the
other mathematics I see it seems kind of
a bit fuzzy and almost II and so fair
enough you know now other people agree
with you I'm gonna do it again and keep
it in exact terms so this is where it
starts to get interesting golden ratio
squared equals golden ratio plus 1 well
you know that ok
golden ratio cubed equals golden ratio
cubed is the golden ratio squared times
the golden ratio we already know that
that is the golden ratio plus one golden
ratio golden ratio squared plus two gold
right but that that equals a good ratio
plus one and so actually that's two
golden ratios plus one
once I simplify that down okay okay okay
we go to golden ratios that's less one
okay golden ratio to the power of 400
well that's that's the same one from
last time they've multiplied it by
another golden ratio to golden ratio
squared plus the golden ratio that is
the God measure plus one so that's two
golden ratios plus two plus that's three
ratios plus two back in here three
ratios plus two now I don't know if you
can see what's happening here but I
might carry this on the next one you do
the same thing you multiply it you
simplify it down five golden ratios plus
three golden ratio to the power of six
is eight golden ratios plus five and
sure enough if you carry down this you
get the Fibonacci sequence here 2 3 5 8
13 and you get it here offset 1 1 2 3 5
8 13 and so on and so the point that has
been raised online is that actually if
you do what I do but you don't do this
ridiculous rounding you keep it in exact
golden ratios and simplify it you get to
lots of the Fibonacci sequence yeah well
played well played internet I I see the
error of my ways
I'm big enough to admit when I'm wrong
it's become a theme it turns out and you
know what I can't I can't argue with
that right so to celebrate the fact that
someone shown me that the Fibonacci
numbers are the best by my own logic
let's do you know what we do to
celebrate things in mathematics we try
to generalize them so let's just
generalize this up a little bit right
and then and then we'll call it a day if
you look here the the power of 3 cuz I
said the enth lucas number is the got
message of that power so the n is that
to the end and that's why I'm calling
this is the first one that's the second
position third position fourth
fifth sixth and so on and so here the
fifth let's take the fifth for example
the fifth power of the golden ratio is
the fifth to Bonacci number because five
is the fifth anniversary number plus the
one below it the fourth one and I quite
like that five is the only Fibonacci
number which is equal to its position
and necessary side fact and so if I want
to generalize this what I've actually
got here is the God ratio 2n equals that
Fibonacci number times the golden ratio
plus the Fibonacci number before it so
if n minus one that's quite nice so
there yeah so we do we would generalize
the pattern whether the oh we can
probably simplify that actually because
we've got a golden ratio here and like
we said the ratio is always golden ratio
as you go up so if n times the God ratio
is actually just the next Fibonacci
number so actually they're equals the
Fibonacci n plus one plus if n minus 1
well that's quite nice so what I've been
correctly schooled on is that the golden
ratio to n is the Fibonacci number after
N and ribbon actually before and some
together that's that is very very
pleasing but actually we probably add
them together couldn't wait could we can
simplify this right because it's always
the Fibonacci number ahead and the one
behind some together so this just very
quickly I can list out the Fibonacci
numbers again 1 1 2 3 5 8 13 21 and then
we'll add the through every position
before and after so 1 and 3 if we add
those together we get so 1 2 we get 3 if
we add 1 2 3 we get 4 if we add 2 to 5
we get 7 3 to 8 we get 11 5 to 13 we get
18 and then we can carry on all the way
up so if you do generalize this and
simplify it down and then you add the
offset Fibonacci numbers you get this
sequence here which is of course the
Lukas not all my goodness where did that
come from so there you are so yes if you
follow the proxy pylons method you do
get the Fibonacci sequence popping out
twice you get two of them one in each
direction but that's because if you sum
the Fibonacci numbers ahead with
see numbers behind you get the Lucas
numbers and so it still is the Lucas
numbers you've just split it into two
Fibonacci numbers but that and no
rounding that is the exact okay there
was some rounding but I hit it
that is the exact lucas numbers coming
out the other side
you look unconvinced brady i you know it
was a solid mass bone you know i should
give them directions to the nearest
maths Department what to be honest they
can probably come back with yet another
argument for why is Fibonacci because it
turns out the two sets of numbers are
very closely linked and the fact that
you can sum pairs of one and you get the
other one is that is why I can flip
backwards and forwards between these
almost at will and the the where the
rounding is gone because you think we
hang on I've just done what I did before
but now the roundings disappeared all
the rounding was hidden in this step
here that's where the rounding was where
I went from there to there because it's
not actually the golden ratio between
consecutive terms it approaches it and
so eventually it's that exactly but
initially you got around for that to
happen and that's why you're rounding
over here to get this so that that's
where all the rounding has been swept
under that one step there and so you
still get the numbers out so I'm thank
you the epoxy pile on for getting
involved and it was a very nice argument
you had been worried for a while but I'm
glad I could sit down and the fact I
could generalize their argument to loop
back to mine that is immensely pleasing
I think I'm well if this round is over
you know but you know I now I throw the
gauntlet down or out or a cross I forget
the relevant direction and if the people
of the internet the netizens want to
rise up and present yet another
counter-argument I am ready
how everyone you might be unsurprised to
know that matt has a bit more to say on
the subject in fact about eight minutes
more it turns into a bit of a
philosophical discussion about the
square root of five and if you'd like to
see that continuation I'm going to post
it on our numberphile 2 channel but you
don't have to wait for it to go public
there there are links to the video
right now on the screen and in the video
description there's also more stuff in
the description about Matt's work and
what he's up to these days so let's just
roll this up people will sing ODEs and
tell tales of the day I felled the proxy
pylon and their attack on the king